beaux souvenirs avec stéphane et en même
temps c'était très douloureux et puis
aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que ça
permettait d'extraire de moi même toute
cette histoire est donc ça m'a apporté
un peu de recul un peu d'apaisement mais
la douleur et la colère seront là
jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
on a tous pensé qu'on descendait du
singe vous avez brisé ce tabou dans une
certaine mesure du genre dont deux
singes le malheur c'est que quand on
deale descente des sages on a
l'impression qu'on descend des
chimpanzés et pas du tout les chimpanzés
et nous savons cousin à grand mère
maternelle qui était bretonne me disais
si toi tu es descendu sa joie sur europe
1 a révélé nous un secret vous en avez
mangé du manu je me trouvera à fouiller
en sibérie et puis un bon matin dans le
trou que j'avais commencé à creuser
je trouve de lait tout comme ce quelque
chose de bien les grands en filaments je
suis étonnée je râle je dirais que ce
sont des collègues russes qui sont venus
tripatouiller le fond de ma recherche et
puis à force de tirer dessus comme rien
ne venait je me suis aperçu que j'étais
sur le dos
[Musique]
à
le résultat un dieu peut réserver bien
des surprises pour mieux comprendre où
vous aideront à y voir clair
[Musique]
le vario mikron sera dominant en france
mais le dépôt de deux bel20 de
déclarations du premier ministre qui
vient de s'exprimer dans la foulée d'un
nouveau conseil de défense sanitaire
lorsque démarre les vacances de noël et
à laquelle l'inquiétude face au co vide
jean castex annonce de nouvelles mesures
et restrictions parmi elles la
transformation pâle sanitaires on passe
vaccinale
dans les hauts-de-seine assume la
responsabilité de la défaite lors d'une
élection locale les conservateurs ont
subi un sérieux revers face aux libéraux
démocrates ces derniers l'ont emporté
dans une circonscription rurale
normalement acquise au parti du premier
ministre britannique un nouveau coup dur
pour boris johnson déjà embourbés dans
une série de scandales et qui fait face
à une résurgence de l'épidémie au
royaume uni
[Musique]
moscou réclame des garanties juridiques
pour assurer sa sécurité qu'elle juge
menacée des propositions ont été remises
aux états unis rendu public
10 elle prévoit d'interdire tout nouvel
élargissement de l'otan à l'ukraine
notamment est d'empêcher les activités
militaires proches de la frontière russe
washington se dit prêt samedi défi
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez cela faisait france
jean castex vient donc de prendre la
parole à l'issue d'un nouveau conseil de
défense sanitaire une réunion pour faire
le point sur une situation sanitaire
préoccupante au moment où débutent les
vacances de noël l'heure des
retrouvailles en famille le gouvernement
s'inquiète face aux risques de
contamination
le premier ministre invite donc à se
faire à tester dans les heures précédant
les moments de fêtes jean castex qui
demande aux mairies de relance et aux
festivités aux nouvelles en concert et
feu d'artifice seront interdits le soir
du 31 décembre le délai du rappel antico
vide et lui réduit à quatre mois au lieu
de cinq actuellement un débat va
également être organisés ou parlement
pour transformer le pass and i ter en
passe vaccinale seule la vaccination
devrait bientôt être valable on fait
tout de suite réagir nos deux invités
bernard plaideront médecin généraliste
membre du syndicat mg france et frédéric
sinclair éditorialiste
bonsoir messieurs chez merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur arte france sur la
forme déjà ce raid eric sinclair comment
est ce que vous avez accueilli cette
allocution de jean castex
écoutez plutôt plutôt
attendu
j'allais dire une partie de prédictions
catastrophistes
comme j'allais à dire comme à
l'accoutumée mais alors pour une fois vu
ce qui se passe dans les autres pays
avec le variant micro non on peut
imaginer que ce soit justifié pour la
nouveau de la nouvelle année ensuite une
série une série de mesures enfin
j'allais dire dans la dans la droite
ligne de ce qui a été la communication
du gouvernement depuis depuis plusieurs
mois alors va revenir évidemment dans le
détail de ces mesures mais est ce que ça
vous semble nécessaire à vous aussi
berlare plaideront cet appel à la
vigilance à l'approché des fêtes de fin
d'année
moi ce que je retiens du discours c'est
que
la fermeté qui est introduite et je
crois qu'il était quand même temps de de
responsabiliser les gens il a fait
beaucoup appel à la responsabilité il y
aura la responsabilité dans mon
comportement pendant les fêtes etc mais
la responsabilité des non vaccinés
vad mise en cause enfin le dire avec le
pass sanitaire qui devient un pass
vaccinale on n'est pas très très loin de
l'obligation vaccinale total je dire moi
c'est un discours qui est cohérent
compte tenu de la gravité de cette
épidémie je veux dire on n'en sort pas
il ya un nouveau variant celle au micron
qui est très très contagieux mais qui
semble ne pas être trop agressif
en revanche s'il ya une nouvelle
variation parce qu'il y en aura de
nouvelles mutations inéluctables et
qu'on a quelque chose d'agressif autant
qu'on ait le maximum de gens qu'ils
soient vaccinés un débat va donc être
organisé au parlement c'est ce qu'a
annoncé à jean castex un débat pour
transformer le passe à lithaire on passe
vaccinale seule la vaccination pourrait
donc bientôt être valable l'étau se
resserre sur les non vaccinés en
frédéric saint clair
wissant sont encore une fois sans que
chiffres à l'appui on puisse avoir la
justification de ce type de politique
premièrement on a de plus en plus
clairement aujourd'hui acquis le fait
qu'on appelle vaccin quelque chose qui
ne l'est pas est un modérateur
d'intensité à la fois modérateur
d'intensité pour les formes graves lubot
directeur de l'intensité aussi pour la
transmission et la contamination c'est à
dire qu'on contamine apparemment on est
moins contaminé une fois qu'on est con
et vaccinés dans décontaminer quand même
et on transmet moins facilement met en
transe mais quand même ils ont fait
moins de forme grave donc un intérêt
évident à ce qu'on appelle vaccin mais
qui n'est pas un qui n'est pas un vaccin
et donc qui pose un sérieux problème je
vous donne deux exemples une à une
toutes petites anecdotes personnelles je
me trouve à cannes cet été est captable
à la sortie d'une d'une boulangerie
espacés de deux ou trois mètres chaque
table
et puis les personnes non vaccinées à
qui on a demandé de passe d'accès el
paso sanitaires qui ont été refusées qui
se sont levés et qui ont été prendre un
café au petit supermarché casino à côté
qui était bondé 40 45 personnes qui
faisaient la queue et plus de place dans
les allées parce qu'on était en plein
été c'est est surchargé en était à
l'intérieur et là tout le monde rend
tout le monde sort et donc vous voyez
bien que il ya quelque part derrière une
forme de mascarade à laquelle les
français adhèrent de moins en moins qui
ensuite une deuxième chose c'est que ont
réduit de plus en plus c'est l'annoncé
ce soir encore on réduit le plus en plus
le le l'espace le temps entre deux doses
on était au début sur au premier vaccin
sûr on fait une dose on est vaccinés on
est tranquille et puis ensuite il a
fallu une deuxième et puis ensuite on a
dit bon pas la troisième ça sera dans
six mois puis finalement 7 et 5 et puis
maintenant c'est 4 et et monsieur
delfraissy a annoncé la quatrième dose
alors que les français n'étaient pas
encore prêts à avoir la troisième sans
parler des médecins autour de moi dans
mon quartier qui me disent dans voudrait
bien vaccinés mais les deux on les a pas
donc vous comprenez bien qu'il ya autour
de cette question vaccinale un enjeu à
la fois médicale mais sanitaires mais
aussi politique il ya un enjeu de
gestion et cet enjeu de gestion les
biens il est manifestement pas rempli
correctement donc à chaque fois qu on
durcit les conditions contre un certain
nombre de personnes en faisant pointer
la responsabilité sur ces personnes
comme si aujourd'hui l'explosion des
taux de d'incidence sur le variant delta
et l'explosion à venir sur omicron était
responsable du à ce petit pourcentage de
personnes non vaccinées on sait très
bien que c'est pas le cas en réalité on
est simplement dans une dans une logique
politique qui vise à prévenir
l'incapacité de l'hôpital à gérer le
flux de malades actuelle est
potentiellement le flux de malades à
venir il me semble que ce n'est pas
forcément la bonne méthode la bonne
approche bernard plédran qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que vous vous dites vous de
cette de ce délai qui est donc ramené à
quatre mois au lieu de cinq actuellement
délais de ce rappel en tic vide qu'est
ce que ça dit de l'efficacité du vaccin
qu'est ce que ça peut changer
non mais avant de revenir sur
l'efficacité je crois qu'ils ont peut
pas laisser dire que ce n'est pas un
vaccin et c'est le débat qu'on a là
c'est un débat de riches je veux dire en
quand l'épidémie a commencé on nous
annonçait une dizaine d'années pour
avoir un vaccin qui sera au point on est
arrivé à voir quelque chose qui marche
quand même dans l'énorme majorité des
cas
au bout de moins d'un an va dire c est
quand on voit l'histoire de la dame qui
s'est fait faire un faux pas ce
sanitaires etc est décédé à l'hôpital je
veux dire c'est pas une maladie tout à
fait anodine je veux dire le vaccin et
c'est un vaccin protège et le
effectivement on le connaît mal parce
qu'on n'a pas le recul qu'on a avec
d'autres vaccins mais qu'il faille 3 ou
4 2 c'est pas le fond du problème le
fond du problème c'est de protéger la
population française et que on a un
variant qui effectivement levitt une
certaine chance il est très très
virulente et très contagieux mais pas
trop agressifs mais quelle serait la
situation si on avait un variant qui
qu'ils ne répondraient absolument pas
aux vaccins en cours veut dire là on
n'est pas dans cette situation après que
le décès le délai soit raccourci comme
le demande y est eh ben c'est tant mieux
parce que
c'est on va augmenter la protection
puisqu'on sait qu'avec la troisième dose
mon buste complètement là la réponse
immunitaire mais
ça fait partie des données qu'on
acquiert au fur et à mesure de la
connaissance du virus et de la réponse
qu'on a mais c'est pas fait mentir mans
illogique le couvert le
premier ministre pardon a également
longuement appelé les français à se
faire tester avant de retrouver leurs
proches ces prochains jours
bernard plédran l'autotest on en a
beaucoup parlé c'est l'une des mesures
en avant aussi pour multiplier les
assurances de ne pas être contaminé
quand on retrouve ses proches qu'elle
engagerait ce que vous portez sur sur
l'auto test qui n'est pas le test anti
sony qui n'est pas non plus le test pcr
c'est quand même mieux que rien
c'est tout à fait mieux que rien mais le
gros le premier ministre offre beaucoup
fait appel à la responsabilité des
sciences aux notes aux tests et qu'il
est positif on sait quand votre
contaminants on a compté contaminés mais
comme vous êtes contaminants pour le
reste de sa famille donc ça nécessite
effectivement de prendre des mesures
d'isolement
surtout en fonction des gens qu'on a
avec nous quand on a des gens très âgés
mal vaccinés ou pas encore vaccinés avec
la 3e 2 et qu'on est en contact avec eux
est ce qu'on a le droit de leur faire
courir des risques supplémentaires
j'avais la question l'autre aujourd'hui
est ce qu'on aime ou on habitait ozon
temps qui lui ne veut pas de vacciner à
la fête de noël moi je lis le tout le
temps il est responsable et cette année
on ne l'invitent pas il a pété question
en revanche lors de cette courte
allocution de jean castex de la
vaccination des enfants comment est-ce
que vous l'expliquer
parce que c'est un succès un sujet c'est
un sujet compliqué c'est un sujet
explosif
pour plusieurs raisons premièrement
parce que on a fait croire aux français
pendant l'été qu'on allait obtenir une
immunité collective et que
le se vaccine s était pas simplement se
vacciner pour se protéger soi même mais
c'était aussi se vacciner pour protéger
les autres on savait déjà grâce aux
études américaines et aux informations
qui avait fuité dans le washington post
que certains kloster aux états unis sur
la côte est avait montré que les niveaux
de charge virale chez les vaccinés non
vaccinées étaient légaux c'est-à-dire
qu'en réalité il y avait une
transmission qui était à peu près égales
c'est c'est la l'université hopkins aux
états unis assez à ces chiffres là ces
données vous pouvez les consulter ses en
libre accès donc fondamentalement on est
parti sur quelque chose qui était erroné
en disant on va vacciner tout le monde
parce que comme ça on va avoir une
immunité collective ce qui avec un
certain nombre de maladies a pris comme
exemple la variole est tout à fait vrai
sauf que c'est complètement faux pour le
couvrir encore une fois on est vaccinés
on transmet un des porteurs du virus et
on transmet donc à partir du moment où
l'on transmet on se vaccine plus pour
l'autre on se vaccine que pour se
protéger soi même donc il ya quelque
chose de très intelligent à dire aux
personnes à risque vaccinez vous puisque
vous êtes à risque revanche pour ceux
qui ne le sont pas et c'est le cas de la
grande majorité des enfants à quelques
cas compliqué chez les enfants mais en
termes de pourcentage c'est extrêmement
faible c'est presque anodin et donc pour
ces personnes là est bien le vaccin peut
présenter un risque mais le bénéfice
n'est pas là et il ya un certain nombre
de médecins je pense par exemple au
docteur de lâcher qui s'expriment
beaucoup en ce moment le docteur québec
aussi sur une chaîne chef chez vos
confrères de lci qui explique qu'en
réalité il vaut mieux pour les enfants
laissez le l'enfant contracté le virus
pour développer une immunité naturelle
qui est de meilleure qualité pour tout
un tas de raisons que je ne maîtrise pas
parce que je ne suis pas médecin mais
que eux semblent maîtriser et donc ils
sont plutôt en faveur de cette immunité
naturelle encore une fois parce que le
vaccin ne n'empêche pas la transmission
le premier ministre jean castex avait
dit il ya quelques semaines seulement je
veux vacciner les enfants parce que ma
fille de 11 ans et celle qui m'a
transmis le virus or on sait que ce
vaccin n'empêche pas la transmission
donc vous voyez bien qu'il ya quelque
chose là qui fonctionne pas et donc
partir du moment je termine en une
phrase à partir du moment où le le
vaccin ne fonctionne pas pour les
enfants c'est explosif de vouloir forcer
les parents à vacciner leurs enfants
alors on va justement faire réagir le
médecin que vous êtes à bernard plédran
sur la vaccination des enfants c'est la
tranche d'âge 6 10 ans qui est
concerné ce que cela ne présente aucun
bénéfice médical pour eux qu'elle est là
quel est le taux d'incidence qu'il
représente dans les cadres de contaminés
soit ce qu'ils sont un vecteur essentiel
de circulation du virus est ce que vous
auriez été favorables à l'obligation de
vacciner
alors je me suis généralement pas
favorable à une obligation générale
comme ça après moi je vais démontrer
beaucoup plus modeste et que monsieur
saint clair dans cette histoire de virus
de kobe disney a fait et herat on
découvre des choses tous les jours moi
j'ai dit des choses en début de pandémie
que je ne regrette pas parce que c'était
surtout au coin du bon sens quand on se
dit je disais aux gens de se laver les
mains et de porter des masques maintien
n'avait pas c'était embêtant et c'était
pas grave pour les enfants que je serai
je suis pas favorable à l'obligation
tant qu'hôtel effectivement il ya des
situations particulières je suis pas
aussi radicale que monsieur saint clair
en disant que le vaccin quand transmet
le virus quand sur le vacciner ou pas ce
n'est pas vrai je sais pas mais mais de
là à ce que les enfants ne soient tous
vaccinés je crois pas que ça soit
indispensable et peut-être que la porte
de sortie pour avoir une immunité
collective passe aussi peut-être par les
enfants pour pour sortir de la crise en
fatah merci
merci pour ce décryptage bernard plédran
médecin généraliste vous êtes aussi
membre du syndicat mg france merci avoue
frédéric sinclair éditorialiste merci et
à bientôt sur rt france
et le varia mikron enquête dans toute
l'europe il explose au royaume uni et au
danemark ces deux pays comptent
aujourd'hui le plus de cas d'infection
de cette nouvelle souche dans le monde
et les autorités s'attendent à ce que
mes craintes de vienne à majoritaire
dans les prochains jours pour y faire
face copenhague ordonne la fermeture des
cinémas des théâtres des salles de
concert un nouveau variant auquel se
préparent à aussi nos voisins allemands
l'allemagne qui vient par ailleurs de
classer la france et le danemark comme
zone à haut risque d'infection je vous
propose d'écouter le ministre allemand
de la santé
je prévois une cinquième vague massive
je suis en contact étroit avec mes
collègues du royaume uni à la fois
politiquement et scientifiquement nous
nous coordonnions hier encore les
collègues disent que ce qui est observé
là bas sur le terrain dépasse tout ce
qui a été observé pendant toute la
pandémie nous devons nous préparer à un
défi que nous n'avons pas encore relevée
sous cette forme
et dans le reste de l'actualité paris
met sa menace à exécution
la france va ainsi demander à la
commission européenne d'engager une
procédure de contentieux contre le
royaume uni elle veut obtenir encore 73
licences de pêche post break site pour
ces pêcheurs des pêcheurs fatigué par
des négociations qui durent depuis 11
mois maintenant le gouvernement va
mettre en place un plan d'accompagnement
pour les professionnels qui sont restés
à quai annonce à l'issue d'une rencontre
à l'elysée dont la journée chez entre le
président macron les représentants des
pêcheurs et les élus des régions
concernées je propose d'écouter le
ministre français clément bonne
il reste quelques dizaines de licence à
obtenir qui sont autant d'embarcations
qui sont autant de familles et qu'on
doit défendre absolument demanderons
aussi dans les prochains jours à la
commission européenne d'engager un
contentieux aux procédures juridiques
pour les licences de auquel nous avons
droit qui sont les plus prioritaires les
plus importantes et une procédure de
contentieux à l'encontre a dû
royaume-uni où boris johnson fait grise
mine le parti conservateur a perdu hier
l'un de ses bastions dans le centre de
l'angleterre lors d'une élection
législative partielle des fêtes qualifié
d' humiliation par la presse britannique
mais que le premier ministre britannique
assume lui déjà affaibli par une série
de scandales et de désaveu politique
sébastien bach
certains pensaient que boris johnson
avait fini par toucher le fond c'était
sans compter un énième revers la défaite
du camp du premier ministre lors d'une
législative partielle en angleterre des
fêtes dont le chef du gouvernement
assume l'entière responsabilité
très clairement le vote dans le nord
struture est un résultat très décevant
et je comprends totalement les
frustrations de tous j'entends ce que
les électeurs disent dans le nord
struture et je dois accepter ce verdict
en toute humilité je dirais que bien sûr
je comprends ce que les électeurs
attendent de nous au quotidien de nous
concentrer sur eux et leurs priorités
une douche froide pour les conservateurs
la circonscription du nord struture
arborait le pavillon des tories depuis
200 ans
ce soir les gens en parler au nom du
peuple ils disent haut et fort à boris
johnson que la fête est finie
votre gouvernement dirigé tout en
mensonge sera tenu pour responsable il
sera examiné contesté et peut-être
vaincu
les tabloïds britanniques parle
d'humiliation de cauchemar avant noël un
cauchemar dont boris johnson a
décidément du mal à se réveiller ces
derniers temps le camp conservateur
devait déjà manoeuvrer avec le scandale
des fêtes du parti à noël dernier alors
que les britanniques étaient soumis à de
fortes restrictions
destinées à freiner la pandémie de
coronavirus il semble qu'il n'existe
qu'une seule règle pour boris johnson
sans club élitiste de downing street et
s'ils sont suffisamment chanceux pour
entrer dans le club tout va bien mais si
vous n'en faites pas partie vous devez
vous conformer aux règles comme tout le
monde
oui les médias en font tout un plat
quand vous considérez que c'est un
environnement de travail c'est un groupe
de collègues il travaille toute la
journée ensemble il dirige le pays et
décide d'organiser une petite fête mais
c'est tout ce que cela représente
je pense qu'ils ne sont pas
consciencieux parce que s'il mettait
vraiment l'intérêt des gens avant les
leurs tout en sachant que ces personnes
traversent une période difficile il
n'aurait pas dû faire cette fête non
une affaire qui s'ajoute aux autres
casseroles que traîne le chef du
gouvernement notamment autour des
rénovations du onze down str8 son
logement personnel pour lesquelles boris
johnson avait reçu un don remboursé par
la suite dans la même période les
activités de lobbyisme de l'élu
conservateur owen paterson ont été
dénoncés c'est d'ailleurs son siège qui
a été remporté ce jeudi par les libéraux
démocrates au parlement le premier
ministre est depuis devenu la cible de
l'opposition
il est clair que le premier ministre
s'accroche désespérément au pouvoir et
je n'ai plus rien à dire à un homme en
qui nous ne pouvons tout simplement pas
avoir confiance donc monsieur le
président il est temps pour les membres
de cette assemblée d'agir s'il ne
démissionne pas alors il doit être
destitué boris johnson plus fragilisée
que jamais pourrait suivre les pas de
theresa may qui avait démissionné en mai
2019 il ne suffit que de 54 députés pour
initier un vote de défiance à son
encontre
hélas les à présent de claude blanchou
les autres experts en relations
internationales
johnson est face à un certain nombre de
scandales on peut le dire probablement
que le plus récent est en effet celui de
la petite fête hot and alain stritt
l'année dernière au moment de noël où
effectivement à un moment où les anglais
était interdit de se rencontrer en tout
cas en dehors du cadre strictement
familial
eh bien on a organisée semble-t-il dans
la dans les bureaux du premier ministre
une petite fête peut être une autre un
peu plus tôt ou un peu plus tard aussi
au siège du parti conservateur et la
faute dans le fond de boris johnson et
d'avoir nié au parlement en effet c'est
un peu une situation qui devient
difficile sinon désespérée pour le
premier ministre lui-même mais encore
une fois la nuit là là là
la situation du parti conservateur en
tant que telle n'est pas menacée puisque
il bénéficie d'une très large majorité
en pleine tension sur la question
ukrainienne les etats-unis se disent
prêts à discuter des propositions russes
en matière de sécurité elles ont été
remises à washington il ya quelques
jours dévoilé ce vendredi alors
qu'américains et européens et le temps
renouvellent leur mise en garde à
l'encontre de moscou accusé de préparer
une offensive militaire en ukraine la
russie démons et propose dont année les
négociations immédiatement la
correspondance de verhaeghe hoffman
la russie est prête à discuter dès
demain des garanties de sa sécurité avec
le temps le vice ministre des affaires
étrangères sergueï riabkov a présenté un
projet d'accord avec l'alliance
atlantique qui inclut des mesures comme
l engagement des états unis à exclure
l'élargissement de l'otan vers l'est
notamment vers des pics et faisait
partie de l'urss dont l'ukraine
parmi les autres demandes du kremlin
obtenir la certitude que la collection
ne construisent pas de bases militaires
sur le territoire des pays du bloc
soviétique je vous propose d'écouter des
myomes aux avis et dans le monde
interdépendant d'aujourd'hui la sécurité
de chaque pays ne peut être assuré que
par la voie de la coopération dans le
cadre du droit international
l'ukraine et la géorgie deviendront
membres de l'otan cela doit être retiré
je te réussit ce chan y proposant
d'inscrire que la russie et les etats
unis ne se considèrent pas comme des
adversaires et que des mécanismes
consultatif sur une base bilatérale et
multilatérale seront utilisées pour
résoudre les situations problématiques
il est également important de réaffirmer
le principe de non-ingérence dans les
affaires intérieures de chacun des deux
blocs drogue sergueï riabkov a également
souligné que ce regain des tensions
entre le temps et la russie étaient
inacceptables et potentiellement
explosif
pour le kremlin les activités des forces
de l'alliance atlantique constatait près
des frontières russes ces derniers mois
n'ont fait que crisper davantage les
relations diplomatiques et doivent
cesser le plus tôt possible et selon un
haut responsable américain les états
unis devrait présenter la semaine
prochaine une proposition sur le format
discussion après avoir consulté les
européens washington lieux et l'otan ont
une nouvelle fois mis en garde moscou
contre de lourdes conséquences en cas
d'intervention militaire en ukraine
l'alliance atlantique et bruxelles ont
rejeté hier la volonté de veto de la
russie quant à la possible adhésion de
kiev à l'otan le récit de thibaut janin
c'était le dossier prépondérant du
dernier sommet européen de l'année 2021
les tensions entre kiev et moscou hier à
bruxelles les vingt-sept ont durci le
ton et mis en garde le kremlin contre de
nouvelles sanctions à l'issue de ce
sommet olaf schulze emmanuel macron se
sont exprimés sur le dossier ukrainien
notre stratégie repose sur sur une une
approche multiple la première s'étant en
effet
l' approche par la dissuasion qui a été
celle à la fois des états unis
d'amérique et du président biden lors de
son échange avec le président poutine et
de l'union européenne sur une situation
que nous connaissons déjà et en envoyant
des signaux très clairs et en ne
coordonnant la deuxième chose c'est de
réengager la russie dans un cadre
politique qui est le seul permettant de
régler la question ukrainienne des
menaces grandi mais qui reste pour le
moment sans véritable action à l'heure
actuelle aucune mesure concrète n'a été
décidé en attendant lieux a reconduit
pour six mois les mesures punitives
imposé à la russie après le rattachement
de la crimée en 2014 moscou a réagi au
prolongement de ces sanctions
économiques
ce n'est pas nous qui avons introduit
les sanctions initial
et ce n'est pas à nous de soulever cette
question vous savez que nous disposons
de tout un ensemble de contre mesures
qui fonctionnent elles vont être
prolongées de manière symétrique de
notre côté
nous considérons toujours que
premièrement ce n'est pas légal du point
de vue du droit international et surtout
que nulle part les sanctions n'ont
permis à leurs initiateurs d'atteindre
leurs objectifs
de son côté l'otan a aussi mis en garde
moscou avec les mêmes termes le
secrétaire général de l'alliance a pris
la parole sur le sujet après une
rencontre avec le président ukrainien
dans le concept de stratégique actuelle
nous faisons référence à la russie comme
un partenaire stratégique
mais depuis lors nous avons assisté à
des actions plus agressive de la part de
la russie nous avons vu la russie ont
envahi hier ses voisins nous avons vu la
russie annexé illégalement la crimée et
continuer à déstabiliser l'ukraine
orientale
jens stoltenberg qui a officialisé une
fin de non recevoir à la liste de
propositions de moscou sur les garanties
juridiques réclamé à l'otan la russie
demande notamment que l'alliance renonce
à sa décision d'ouvrir la porte à
l'adhésion de l'ukraine et de la géorgie
et c'est la fin de cette édition se
retrouve dans une trentaine de minutes
pour un nouveau journal à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
cette semaine on va passer en revue
l'actualité économique une bonne partie
des économistes qui pensent que tout ce
qui a été fait a été bien fait que
structurellement l'économie va bien que
le chômage a vraiment été vaincue que le
pib a augmenté moi je vois pas où sont
les fondamentaux qui sont bons ben non
justement problème c'est que la bourse
elles montrent simplement parce que les
banques centrales injectent de l'argent
le monde entier sous perfusion là on a
un vrai problème on ne sait pas comment
débrancher la perfusion quand vous
déversez comme ça et que vous endetter
pour faire 5 10 % de déficit budgétaire
évidemment vous avez un résidu qui
arrive en pipe et heureusement faut
arrêter de prendre les gens pour des
imbéciles et leur annoncer à chaque fois
que demain l'herbe est plus verte parce
que demain malheureusement l'est rebelle
et
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend saft
est ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre
il est probable qu'il faille prendre un
certain nombre de mesures un peu
autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous
l'uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inutile gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on